thank you very much from good morning
and welcome to our conference so I'm
going to talk today there's going to be
a number of talks about our cloud
technologies and things that are using
it and Conrad gave some sort of
introduction to this so I'm going to
sort of dive dive in and have a look so
the idea is to give an overview of the
platform and describe some of the
benefits and the features in the
technology but I'm trying to give a sort
of big a big picture view of the whole
thing not not too focused on small
details or aspects of it so before we
came to build our cloud we had some
other pieces that were that were useful
and I'm just going to look look through
some of these so we had a Wolfram
language so it's conrad was saying it's
a concise literate high level
programming language also something that
we're working on and evolving and i can
talk about that maybe not in this talk
but i'd be interested to talk about that
obviously computation evident in the
name of Mathematica since the very
beginning we wanted to support lots lots
of computation but we also want to move
move in new directions so for example
data science sometimes they're not
necessarily their new names rather than
new directions so gain beginning we've
had a computable documents CDF's
notebook documents lots of people like
to use them for making presentations and
they're very powerful ways of sharing
sharing your work we have our sort of
knowledge integrated computable data
that integrates with the system and
we'll wolfram alpha is an aspect of that
and we've also had a number of server
technologies that have worked so there's
a thing called web Mathematica that I
know some of you have used
and so this is kind of an antecedent of
our cloud so I just want you know people
talk about clouds and cloud technologies
sometimes it's a bit hard to sort of
like mathematics it's a bit hard to pin
down really what it is even though
everybody has some familiarity with it
and I tend to think of a cloud as a
network of Internet and enabled devices
so all these things kind of a sort of
hooked up and they're using Internet
type technology probably web servers
probably HTTP the clouds also relate to
other concepts so enterprise computing
that's that's a long-established concept
focused on individual organizations may
be a company that might have databases
and different roles of users and the
idea is the the enterprise computing is
you know it's not just an individual
person it's a whole organization another
thing somewhat related to is is grid
computing how to make a sort of big
supercomputer out of lots of individual
networked computers so that's that's
let's get going so why why bother with
what are some of the benefits reasons
for going to a cloud solution and so
I've listed some of them here zero
configuration you know often end users
are working through browsers everything
gets downloaded immediately you don't
have to install things you don't have to
worry about versioning it just arrives
very convenient another thing that's
getting more more important in number of
ways is this device location
independence and that might be device
independence you know I'm using a laptop
I'm using a smartphone a tablet so
mobile is an important part of that and
another
form of this independence is something
where you're working with different
types of computer you know my one
department uses windows another one uses
linux and other one uses macs and the
cloud makes it convenient to sort of
Mary these things together and that's
that's that's that's kind of an
important thing so sharing collaborating
between people it's all network based
that's that's that's that's a nice
feature um security so since some of the
data and the code might often be held
centrally and it's delivered down
through browsers or or it's worked with
on the server there's there's there's a
security feature there's a bunch of sort
of more technical things so you know
scalability and reliability you know you
don't if there's a problem you just fix
it on the server area you don't need to
go and you know sort of you know you
don't have to download patches to all of
your users so these are some of the
benefits and then I might distinguish
between a couple of directions so we
might think of a cloud application so
this is like a an application like a
word processor or a spreadsheet and
end-use at all resides in a browser
could be mobile and it's it's a desk
like a desktop application that's
implemented with the cloud again you
know many of the benefits I was talking
about a relevant here and I think this
is becoming an important trend in
computer technology another alternative
you know trend of cloud is a cloud
program so this is something that's
programmer oriented so it's not really
something a user a human being is
interacting with directly into something
a program is calling another program and
it's it's it's kind of you know building
things in the cloud has these these
things in the cloud is kind of has
you know again useful one of the big
benefits of these cloud programs is sort
of connecting them up often is very
simple deployment using using HTTP so
let's just think about in the Wolfram
world what these things mean so we would
tend to think of a cloud application
this is delivering and viewing CDF's
notebook documents and a cloud program
would mean delivering and executing
Wolfram language code so let's just go
straight in and look at cloud what we
call cloud CDF so this is notebooks on
the web and so I'll just bring up a
browser we come in so I'm running
actually I'm running on my laptop here
i'm running a private cloud and i'll
talk about those in a bit more detail
and i can just come on so now i've
switched from Mathematica I'm now
running a browser and I can come and you
know make a title work and you know this
is this is Mathematica so I can just
make a do do sort of Mathematica type
work and this is a all running in the
browser and if I can type better so
there's no there's no plugin there's no
I didn't have to install anything i just
pointed my browser at a website and
everything started started to work let's
fix the you know and it's just a you
know a notebook document I mean it looks
it looks so similar often I'm maybe
there are some of you here you know this
this is a browser it's not it's not
regular Mathematica and these cloud
CDF's support a lot of the features you
know support I mean our mission is to
support everything to make them work
just as well as
the you know things about manipulating
dynamic and other features and such like
there's a talk later i think it's late
later today that young push go is giving
that where yarns going to talk in much
more detail about the the implementation
and features of of cloud notebooks it's
it's it's a big interesting story so
this some this cloud cdf that i've
created here is very works you know it's
it's very similar I could you know sort
of download this I could open this in in
mathematica dude do you know sorts of
things like that I can keep it in the
cloud but since it's in the cloud I can
do other things with this that are quite
convenient so for example I could come
here and I could add you know
collaborators so I could share the
document with people so it's just
visible to it specific people who have
to have cloud accounts or I could make
it public so that anybody could look at
it so I can do things like that I could
come and make some embeddable content so
that people can look at it in all sorts
of different ways you know I can
generate a here's a little bit hard to
see here but I can generate the sort of
you know some bit of HTML that I could
paste into a web page so that I would
then embed this notebook in in some
other in some other document so that's
the idea of cloud cloud notebooks and
yeah right it's it's really is a viable
form of notebooks totally purely a web
technology note no plugin so as we saw
in the browser here we've got this
little file file viewer here and I've
got a bunch of notebook
here but but I can put other types of
other types of document into it and so
one thing that I could do is good so I
could have files say for example HTML
files and this this shows us a principle
of the system so I've opened some of you
will know what hTML is some of you won't
doesn't really matter if you don't know
what it is this this is the language
that drives that browsers render that's
how they show you the stuff in the
browser and I can come in here and I can
you know sort of edit I get a little bit
of it's not a really powerful HTML
editor but it's somewhat somewhat useful
but what's nice is I can switch from
looking at it like this I can see a
deployed view of the HTML and so here I
see what the HTML actually is and so
what we have at least this similar
concept works in other types of files is
that really our cloud is really quite a
viable system for building interesting
websites that do different different
sorts of things it's not just notebooks
it can be web web content as well so
we're really trying to sort of bring
together the web mathematica and the
sort of notebook things together in one
in one system it's the sort of cloud
cloud files now I want to talk about
cloud functions so this is building with
working with sort of you know the
material this is more writing doing
programming but using the using this you
know you're using the web so the key
underlying feature for this is just
going to connect to so I've set up is
this concept of cloud objects so first
of all I'm connecting
I've connected to the cloud and I give
the you know in default I give the cloud
base so this is the URL that I've set up
for the private cloud that I have on my
system so you can do that all of these
things you can do them in our public
cloud or if you have a private cloud you
can you can do this sort of thing what
I'm going to do is do a cloud put and so
this is putting the you know first
hundred digits of pi into a cloud object
and we get back this cloud object thing
with this URL here and then if we click
on this URL then we see it's a bit
boring it's just showing you the you
know the digits of pi so that's not not
totally interesting i can i can upload
it to the cloud i can download it like
so and of course these commands they'll
work you know I have to say there's
permissions and things but I can do the
the nice thing about this is that given
that I'm you you know this has got the
the cloud base I can I can execute these
commands anywhere anywhere in the world
I could be running in a cloud notebook I
could be running in a mathematica I
could be running anywhere and I can
access the these these cloud objects and
they have this this thing called the
uuid which is this big sort of name that
you know with some sort of mathematical
analysis is designed so that you know
you can create it locally but you'll
never get collisions of these uu IDs
here I went to get some information
about the the object and you see some
you know the uuid and there's like names
and permissions and things like that and
there's all sorts of things I can give
to you know to set set set these up so
that's in itself is a bit boring you
know like why do we why do we care about
these cloud objects well let's start to
do some programming so now I'm going to
do cloud evaluate so if i do cloudy
you ate machine name so if i do machine
named locally i get my my my my my
laptop but if i kiled evaluate of dollar
machine name I get the private cloud
that's that's the name of the machine
that the private cloud that I'm running
and again this is a simple way to
evaluate things in the cloud it's a you
know again it's it's not necessarily so
useful in itself other than a simple
sort of test but now we start to get
things that are more useful so now i'm
going to talk about api functions so
here i'm defining a an api function and
it takes one argument X which has to be
an integer and then here's the body of
the function so it's going to add that X
2 3 and that's my API function I can
call that directly here but I can also
deploy it so new new concept I'll deploy
I can deploy this to the cloud so I cup
here I get a URL so I'm calling this
from a browser since I didn't give it
the argument it returns an error at web
page error so i could put in the the
argument and then send the API request
none if you can see up here I get the
answer 203 and if you see the API
function it's actually made a made a
call and it's put the argument this is
how one of the ways that the web sends
you send arguments to things it'sit's
put the argument up there now the nice
thing about this function is I can call
it from any any other programming
language that knows how to make HTTP
requests which is just about any other
programming language modern programming
maybe all fortran 77 didn't know how to
do didn't know how to do HTTP but
languages now know how to do that and so
i'm now
taking the the uuid here in fact I can
just show you so I'm doing the so
there's my my URL and I'm doing doing
this from Mathematica I'm doing URL
fetch and it's making the call and the
results coming back now in these api
functions there's all sorts of extra
commands for setting set the formatting
or i want to see more than the result i
might want to see messages or errors or
timeouts or things like that so i can
there's there's like a big big language
of these things in in api function but
this is a pretty useful way to make a to
deliver mathematical code i just have to
make an API function deploy it and then
I can call this from any other language
setting permissions and such like now
here's another way to deploy
mathematical functions and this is to
embed the API function in a form now of
course I could go and write some
JavaScript and HTML that called the API
function but we've done that for you and
so we have this thing called the form
function so again it looks very similar
to the API function and I can call it in
the same sort of way but now when we
deploy this we get to see that it's a
bit different so the form function
actually has a user interface a form
that comes comes around it so this is
the same old boring function that adds
adds numbers together so this is a form
function and I've got a slightly more
interesting example and there's more
examples of this that we're coming up
with later in the in the conference I
think think Anthony's got some we'll
look at some more um but here I've got a
form function and I'm calling a another
feature that we added in
at matok attend which is this idea of
notebook templating i'll be talking more
about this in my talk on data science
platform tomorrow but this is a way to
create a notebook document based upon a
template notebook so I give the name of
the template and the parameters that I'm
filling out there so now this form is
going to return a cloud CDF and I'm
giving a little bit more stuff here so i
define this function and then i deploy
it so now this so I've got the form it's
got more fields and there's a big
language for setting different different
elements in the form and i'm going to
type in something like and this is now
running a command that's created a
notebook document and so this is one
that so i've i've created a CDF but I
created as you know the CDA it didn't
exist before I just created it when I
filled in the form and it you know you
know I put in sign or here i'll put in
some and then you can put in some
Mathematica
yo put in some sort of mathematical
function and then we get some you know
more more more result so this form
obviously the form could be looking up
users in your database and making a plot
or you could be doing some financial
analysis or other other types you know
looking up students and plotting their
or students could be submitting work or
or things like that but it's it's it's a
nice sort of integration of these
different technologies that we have so
that's the form function and so the the
combination of these things in our cloud
technology with cloud CDF's with our
form functions with our API functions is
allowing us it this is now a pretty nice
interesting way to build micro sites so
these are like websites that do
interesting things that we can put
together quite easily and they're pretty
scalable to large systems so Conrad was
showing I'm not going to give a demo of
the image identify site but this is how
this is how we're Wolfram research built
built image identify so we so we put it
together with a private cloud and
various combinations of API functions
and form functions and hosting the the
web content in the cloud and we were it
was a pretty streamlined way to create
what what is you know really quite a fun
fun site thats actually had very
significant amounts of usage so it was a
big big you know we were very pleased
with the a the the minimum of effort it
took us to put the thing together and be
the the type you know the interest that
that it achieved right so now i'm going
to move away from some demos and try to
talk about some of the technologies we
have and how they fit together so i'm
going to look
at contrasting first of all contrasting
our cloud and pre cloud so this is an
look here a little bit about how a
traditional i call this non cloud but it
it might be sort of pre Cloud Desktop
Mathematica this is Mathematica running
on your personal computer so traditional
Mathematica it runs Lizard as an
application you could run this you know
maybe inside your company but the point
here is that you have an individual user
and they're doing all these nice things
with the system but it's all local to
one machine that you're just running it
on one machine so like if we want to do
sharing of documents then that's going
to have to be done very much with you
know I create the document locally if I
want someone else to see it I can email
it to someone and when when that came
along that was a very sort of powerful
concept but it has some has some you
know some issues it means the person
that I'm email it to they need to have
Mathematica or or a player for it and if
they don't have it they can't do
anything with with the document now
instead of emailing it of course I could
upload it to a server and then you know
the other person could could download it
and that's kind of and that's that's of
nice popular powerful way we have our
demonstrations websites which which is
built from from a concept like that but
there are some issues with this that
that you need to think about so if I
share a document like this with a
co-worker then we've each got two copies
of the document so everybody's working
on copies of the documents and if we
make edits or changes we've got to email
them back and forth and integrate them
so it's it's hard to sort of propagate
changes between the things
so that's a negative let's talk about
running code so here I've got the user
this is all done locally so the cloud
the local user you know starts loads up
a document loads files and things and
then they hit shift enter and this thing
goes through a compute cycle so it's
it's running locally sharing code
between you know I've got it similar to
the CDF thing or I've got to copy files
there's no and of course I can calculate
lots of great things and I can save the
results or put this results in a
database or email them that's that's all
very nice but but one of the the key
things that that's a little bit negative
is it's there's no server operation for
this there has to be a human being
sitting there hitting shift enter and
you know if you want the calculation to
run it through a clock in the morning
then the human being has to go there at
three o'clock in the morning web
Mathematica can solve this and we do
have some sort of scripting ways of
launching the system but still it's not
supporting a server operation quite
quite so conveniently let's look at data
loading and saving well Mathematica in
the Wolfram language we have lots of
features for importing and exporting and
linking tools and you can connect you
know in all sorts of ways to to you know
different data actually since you can
run this inside a company there are some
benefits of this because you know you're
inside firewalls so connecting to a
database and everything works works
pretty well now let's come and look at a
cloud so our public cloud so now this
thing here it's it's a cloud user that's
maybe you know logged in through through
you know a cloud notebook it's all
running same types of operations or
running in the public cloud but let's
look at how some of these things work so
sharing documents with a sharing of
documents
is kind of a built-in feature of the
system there's like workflows to make it
convenient to add set permissions and
email the the a hyperlink a URL so so
the user initial user makes a document
but the document lives in our cloud and
sharing is via hyperlinks or URLs so so
the co-worker does not need any does not
need a you know a plug-in they just need
a browser and the same they might all be
working on a mobile device so a tablet
and same thing they think they could
work with it and there's just one
version of the document so updates and
things propagate very quickly running
code built-in system but now we've got
some more opportunities to run code so
then in our cloud we can have the same
cloud user can load up their doc you
know code and do shift enter but we've
got more ways of running this is the
sort of cloud compute so I'll that's
running here but we can launch the
computation in some new ways that were
not not possible before so we could have
the we could have an API function that i
just showed showed show to you so that
could be calling from a computer
somewhere else making a call through the
API function running the computation
could even be an embedded device like
like a raspberry pi of some sort of
small you know tiny little device but
just you know just needs to be able to
connect to the web that can launch a
computation and then another way that
we've added I'll talk more about this
tomorrow is we can have computations
running in the clouds that run on a
schedule so every night at three o'clock
in the morning you don't have to get out
of bed to do shift enter it you know the
server does it for you so if you want to
run a report so that it you see the
result in the morning that's that's
that's that's that's that's how
works so data loading and saving is
pretty similar now one of the things
here in a way we're running in the
public cloud so there might be access to
private data issues so that's that's the
thing there now let's come and talk
about private clouds so this is a
private cloud is another if it's a
mathematica it's a Wolfram cloud but it
lives in a virtual machine and you can
run it wherever you want I'm actually
running 11 here so this is my I'm
running it's a virtualized machine i'm
running this in virtualbox on my laptop
you know I could sort of log in it's
just another computer that sits here and
you can run this wherever you want has
very similar features and you can use it
in very similar ways to the public cloud
but it's one for you to run yourself and
that makes it very much an enterprise
product and you might well run it in
your intranet its private to you so you
that makes it easier to control access
to your data and also you control use
usage you're not competing with other
other users in the cloud you're you're
controlling the the usage so I put that
you know this is it's all running in
your intranet so sharing documents is
you know some of these features are
going to work in a similar way to the
way it worked before except it's all
secure it's all private to you and your
coworkers so that might be good for
running private I'd it you know sharing
private ideas running code similar it's
in the intranet secure for private ideas
and data and loading data now this is
also quite convenient because there's
the private cloud but I can read and
write from a local database in the in my
intranet so that's the benefit of the
private cloud
so another thing and this is something I
think we're starting to see an
interesting way that there's also quite
unique to our cloud technology is this
way of connecting desktop and cloud and
that there are benefits to both of them
sometimes having a local accesses is
convenient sometimes having cloud access
and so we've set things up so that
things were quite conveniently and in
different phases of your work sometimes
when you're working you might have a
prototype phase so in the prototype
phase you might work entirely locally
you know you load the data you're
working on your local computer in
Mathematica and you can run calculations
and test things out and you can do all
the same things running running in the
cloud and then when you go to a setup
phase what you do here is you're going
to take your your functions that you've
written you can upload CDF's you can
upload package files you could make API
functions and upload those to the cloud
so this Cloud Desktop duality
hybridization two things working
together is is a powerful concept so I'm
running on my Macintosh laptop here and
i'm using a Chrome browser the other
browsers work just fine and that's
that's all very nice but it's also
useful to have the clouds working with
mobile and these server things actually
lend themselves that quite quite nicely
and we have several mobile projects
going on Wolfram research the most
advanced ones were working for iOS and
one of the ones that's quite the most
advanced of those is an app for working
with the cloud so this uses web
rendering for the notebooks and I've
just got some sort of simple screenshots
here that I've taken I don't have a demo
of this but these are that's the cloud
and here's that kind of like a cloud you
know notebook running in our
ipad version it actually looks very
similar you know it actually looks very
similar but this this is a screenshot
where it says iPad down there and
different screenshots of the of this
cloud document it's pretty nice to be
able to share documents and have them
show up on the you know some of these
work a bit better on the size of the
screen that you get so with our core
technologies we've we've built a number
of products that from the core
technology the core and we built a
number of platforms and so we talked
about these with with Mathematica we
talked about these and we talk about our
cloud so a key one is mathematical
online and this is very much traditional
Mathematica Mathematica notebooks that
works through a browser in the cloud so
probably for a number of you the one
that would be most familiar we also have
a programming cloud and so this is using
trying to focus and enhance the
programming features and then we have
our data science platform I won't go
into this in detail but that's taking
the game trying to build a platform that
tries to collect workflows that are
convenient for data science and i'll be
showing that tomorrow for the usage the
public cloud it's a subscription-based
system there's different you know
interactive cloud notebooks you get a
subscription level and then you can
deploy CD cloud CDF's or api functions
and there's we have this concept of
cloud credits that you buy card closets
and you get some sort of dashboard that
comes up and you can see how many
credits how many credits you have and
what help how that's going private cloud
uuuugh license the private cloud then
you can use it as you want so that's
that
that's a simplification of the private
cloud security we've we've got we have
this Wolfram ID thing documents and
things a private to each Wolfram ID the
Mathematica engine the colonel runs in a
sandbox mode which which restricts file
access and suchlike in the private cloud
of course you can customize these and if
you want your private cloud to run see
executables and things like that you can
you can customize it there's also a
permission system for notebook documents
and cloud cloud objects in general and
you can set different levels of
permission and read write execute and
public there's there's a nice permission
system just run down here how does how
does our cloud relate to some of our
existing products so just stop
Mathematica I gave some idea it with our
cloud hybridization it fits in very well
with with this with workbench we've been
adding integration features to integrate
the clouds with with work then so you
can push your project up to the cloud or
integrate it in in that sort of way some
time we'll probably investigate a
cloud-based IDE web Mathematica web
Mathematica is actually the engine
behind the cloud so the development will
continue on we'll probably I mean web
Mathematica will definitely continue
we're probably looking now to host web
mathematica material inside the cloud
and grid Mathematica we're also
developing integration of the cloud with
grid Mathematica so I'll just summarize
and then we can go and have coffee I was
trying to give you a big picture
overview of our cloud platform this this
really now is a viable system we're
really starting to use it at Wolfram
research
search and I encourage any of you to try
get a cloud account and try it try
things out try try to build things and I
know that there's a bunch of people here
who are interested in coming to talk
about all sorts of different aspects of
that I gave you some of the benefits of
the cloud platform and compared desktop
public and private clouds looked at the
workflows that these enhanced and
supported and why some of them were
useful and then I looked at subscription
level security and some of the rated
products anyway I would encourage you
all to try try our cloud and I think
it's an interesting way to move forwards
so thank you very much